hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to continuous and indie
Horrigan that actually kind of emulates
the style and theme of Silent Hill PT in
that the developer wanted to make a game
that was supposed to be endlessly
looping now I think this means that the
game also doesn't have an ending period
but I'm gonna ignore that for now
because other people have been saying
that it's a very very well made game and
I know I've heard that before I know
I've said that before but this one
actually had a solid solid rating and a
lot of the reviews said it was just a
solidly good game special thanks to the
following and provided pieces of audio
for the game okay so we got some
royalty-free stuff I'm hoping that means
I'm not gonna hear the same sounds I
hear in almost every horror game I ever
play Stanislaw Trochowski let's see
which oh hello oh it's very nice it's
kind of a lot like the hallway that I
played from San Lee opt I won't make too
many comparisons to that particular game
because I know that this one is its own
game and just because it was emulating
the the theme of being endlessly looping
does not mean that the whole look at
that ain't data clever
Oh ain't dead - okay alright
you can flicker the lights a little bit
that ain't too bad
wait am I crazy okay so I thought for a
second there all of the doors were gonna
loop back to the same hallway that it
was at before that would have been just
too crazy okay so I can't go in that one
yet if it's anything like Silent Hill PT
that means that door is gonna open up
eventually and there's gonna be all
baby-talking man babies here a talking
man baby in any of these things no okay
all right then I'm just gonna be on my
way alright has anything okay that
happened before I don't know if that
means there's gonna be anything
different now but that
oh hey hello mr. camera what are you
doing in here okay why is there a camera
just sitting on the floor of the baby
room oh that is some flash that
battery's not gonna last for a while all
right
so I'm only using the camera's flash to
be able to see in the dark when
something horrible happens I guess this
is just a heads up there's gonna be
flashing lights if that wasn't very
evident already huh I don't know if
there's gonna be anything new okay this
is a towel rack whoa
I'm sorry Oh God okay am I locked in
here oh hey hey hey let me out now you
don't need to do this to me let me out
please oh boy this isn't gonna end well
for me hello no one's home shut up go
away
okay
I'm gonna happen waiting damn since it
series if me flashing the light over and
over I don't know if that means I'd like
to move on with my horror journey
experience hello okay I'm a just talking
a bathroom I don't know if I really
don't know what I'm supposed to do am I
supposed to take a bath
the clothes will wash my hands before I
go what do you want oh okay then the
Georges fell off
why okay please tell me the rest of the
houses at least got to be lit up because
it's flat okay pardon
okay okay
all right then okay good grave fantastic
for me yeah thing some kind of
uncomfortable I need a little bit more
space is that the paper room that I'm
here playing what I guess yeah don't
tell me I want to be locked in here
again ding dong ding dong what does that
mean
okay nothing in here but then again
there wasn't anything in here before was
there I don't know if the flash is gonna
like reveal anything at all I'm just
gonna have to keep looping give this
door is back on its hinges but I'm not
going in there
screw that oh okay
that's horrible why would you do that to
me huh
do the emergency backup generators kick
on I need to find out about this okay
I'm just giving here I'm here right now
I'm just gonna go home I'm gonna go away
now thanks for nothing oh god I can't I
can't I can't do the door
hahaha maybe I gotta go back the way I
came because I know at some point in PT
you had to do that maybe or maybe I'm
mistaken okay nope Dow's a lie yeah oh
no baby no no baby no no ain't no baby
in there you can't fool me okay alright
then
you're my way God baby stop crying I had
to deal with this in the other game okay
I didn't see anything oh god damn with
you this is digging with me at this
point I mean I know it's what horror
games are want to do to me but still why
does it need to happen I just needed God
oh okay
all right everything's okay everything's
totally cool everything's awesome and
fine that's a bad that's a bad hello
baby
there was a baby here I'd Rockets asleep
oh so gently and my big manly arms hello
it's dark in here now oh can I turn on
the Fu's box I think that's the fuzes
over there turn that on ah yes no god
damn it thought I was gonna be here
ah alright then I'll just keep going
around oh it's already open what was
that okay I'm gonna move on now go move
right along the southern make any
goddamn sense wait what this is wait a
minute no I'm turn I'm either turning
around and something has gone horribly
horribly wrong I'm an adventurer guess
that something has gone horribly
horribly wrong
ain't no baby Oh God why as a moose baby
as a cow baby it's a cow moose baby
hybrid okay have we reached some
semblance of normal again
oh no we have not okay I just wondering
just asking a question
was that has that always been there the
damn phone that's a thing that's
definitely a thing I hear oh okay sorry
haha
loser now oh god yeah I died I died oh I
didn't die everything just went blue oh
the phone that must not have been there
because I would have noticed it
otherwise you've not behind me okay
ah you liar
big liar you son of a [ __ ] lawyer don't
say things that you're gonna follow up
on still in there I can't open that door
anymore rot whoa wait a minute
Wi-Fi huh yeah okay nevermind everyone
and during that place was a bad idea
oh god that door won't open either
okay
that's something I should be worried
about or is that what I heard someone
talking about in the comments they said
what the they were confused about the
ending of the game because there was
this noise in loot that it
Cynthia another game him I don't know if
that's it uh okay
can't open this door
I don't know exam
I don't know it's going on tonight now
go back I can't go back okay so I think
I think that might be the end I'm not
entirely sure I'm pretty sure it might
be the end unless unless I can flip the
breaker on this time
nope okay that's not a thing I think I
don't know I think the games at the end
ah man who's just getting good then
again this is the guy's first experiment
in the game but it's actually really
really good oh man if this is the end
I'd feel bad if it wasn't the end but
I'm pretty sure that is it so since this
is the only thing I can see I think this
might be it I will wait around a little
after I do it's out here but hey it is
what it is it was really good for what
it was I mean it was short but
interesting so interesting so I hope you
guys enjoyed it also I wanted to mention
that I'm going to be starting up another
a long horror series in the near future
I'm going to be leaving 4 packs out next
week so I think it's a good time that a
kick one off again now my plan is to hit
up I know there's so many that you guys
are wanting me to do and I'm gonna hit
them selectively one at a time but the
one that I'm going to be starting very
soon if you guys want it is Fatal Frame
I got recommendation for many people
including game grumps they said that
Fatal Frame 2 was an exceptionally
terrifying and good story for a horror
game so I think it'd be a good fit for
me to play and then obviously there are
many sadly no games with let me know
what you think let me know what you want
me to bleh if you're okay with Fatal
Frame 2 let me know in the comments
below let me know what other suggestions
you have for a longer let's play because
I know it's about time that I started in
another one either way thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
for more scary games that I've done in
the past and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye God everything is
wrong terrible everything is horrible
Oh
oh no no no great event